افادت مصادر اعلانيه بسماع ما لا يقل عن
ثلاثه انفجارات ضخمه في مدينه اصفهان
والصيران وبحسب المصادر وقع الانفجار في
احد مراكز التصنيع الذخائر التابعه لوزاره
الدفاع الايرانيه وجاء في بيان مساعد
محافظه اصفهان للشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه
انه لن تقع اصابات الانفجارات فيما تعمل
قوات الانقاذ والان المتواجده في الموقع
على تفريق الحشود المتواجده في مكان
الحادث
اذا مشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور الاوليه
التي تظهر هذا الانفجار في اصفهان والذي
قيل بانه عند مصنع عسكري اذا انفجار في
مصنع عسكري في مدينه اصفهان الايرانيه كان
هناك حديث من شهود عيان عن تحليق طائره
مسيره وايضا سماع اصوات مشابهه لاطلاق
مضادات جويه قرب مصنع الذخيره في اصفهان
الى الان لا يوجد اي تاكيدات رسميه حتى
الان حول طبيعه هذه الانفجارات ما الذي
تسب بها واا ما اذا كانت قد نتجت عن هجوم
بطائره مسيره او تعرض
المصنع الانفجار داخلي الى الان همم لا
يوجد اي معلومات كل ما قالته السلطات
الايرانيه بانه لم يخلف همم
اضرارا همم بالارواح لم تسقط ضحايا لكن
هناك عمليات انقاذ واطفاء
ومساعدات على كل حال ينضم الينا همم من
دبي الصحف المتخصص في شيء مسعود الفجر
ماذا نعرف عن طبيعه هذه الانفجارات
والمكان الذي وقعت به
تحياتي لك والمشاهد الكرام
الانباء تتحدث عن انفجار في الانباء
الرسميه الحكوميه تتحدث عن انفجار في مصنع
لذخيره في اييي في اصفهان نعرف اصفهان
تعتبر مدينه صناعيه وفيها منشات عسكريه
متعدده في مختلفه المجالات في في الذخائر
في الطائرات المشيره في تصنيع الدبابات
وما شابه ذلك بالاضافه الى ان هذه هذه
المحافظه تضم احدى اهم المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه وهي منشات همم المعروفه
الا ان هذا الانفجار يبدو هو قريب من
المدينه من عاصمه المحافظه التي ايضا
اسمها اصفهان اصفهان هي عاصمه محافظه
اصفهان ايضا الان ااه يتحدث لو ااه الشريط
الذي عرضته الفيديو يتحدث باللغه الفارسيه
يقول احفاده اي طائره مسيره
وتتكرر كلمه قحطان اي طائره مسيره في في
هذا الشريط وفي الاشرطه الاخرى الان بعض
همم بعض الانباء تتحدث ايضا عن انفجار في
كرج الا انه غير مؤيد بعض المصادر
الاسرائيليه نقلت عن انفجار في كراج لو
كان لو كان هجوم بطائره مسيره بسبب همم
كثره الانفجارات هي ليس الانفجار واحد او
اثنين او ثلاثه يبدوا هناك سلسله من
الانفجار
يعني همم اللحظه التي وقع فيها الانفجار
يبدو انه سبقها انفجارات اخرى دعت الناس
للوقوف والتقاط عدسات الهواتف لالتقاط هذه
الصور اي انه لم يكن انفجار الاول خصوصا
ان هناك عدد من الماره في الشوارع كانوا
يتجمهرون السؤال هل يمكن ان ااه تكون هذه
الانفجارات ناتجه همم عن ضعف اجراءات
الامن والسلامه في المصانع الايرانيه
لكونها ليست المره الاولى وكثيرا ما عزت
ايران وقوع هذا النوع من الانفجارات الى
حدوث حوادث داخليه
كل الامور وارده لا يمكن الجزم والتاكيد
مئه بالمئه بان الام كان نتيجه
لانفجار داخل المصنع او نتيجه
لهجوم بطائرات مسيره واستهداف هذا المصنع
لا يمكن الجزم بذلك ولكن المشكله هي في
السلطات الايرانيه لا تعطي صوره اوليه
تشد الطريق على على الاشاعات بسبب اعطاء
معلومات ناقشه دائما عن احداث مشابهه
تفتح الطريق امام كثير من التكاثر
كانت صحيحه مثلا الانفجارات التي حصلت في
في في
واا انكرتها السلطات الايرانيه جاء همم
محسن رضائي فاعترف بذلك او مثلا سرقه الوث
النوويه الايرانيه من ترك جباد بالقرب من
طهران انكرتها السلطات الايرانيه عندما
اعلن نتنياهو في المرحله السابقه لرئاسه
الوزراء همم فانكرت ذلك فجاء محسن رضائي
وايضا كشف بان تمت سرقه ال- ال- الوثائق
النوويه الايرانيه لذا عدم الثقه
بالمصادر همم الاخباريه الايرانيه
والاعلام الايراني الرسمي الذي هو يجب ان
يقدم صوره عن ذلك
يجعل الامور مفتوحه على كل احتمالات ايضا
كان هناك عمليه اغتيال للعالم
النووي الايراني وبالتالي ايران الى اي
مدى مخترقه من قبل اسرائيل والى اي مده
هناك امكانيه ان تكون هذه واحده من عمليات
الاستخباراتيه الاسرائيليه وهل يمكن تنفيذ
هكذا نوع من الهجمات ربما بشكل سيبيراني
من خلال متابعتك لهذا الملف
[موسيقى]
منذ سنين بدات الهجمات السيبرانيه اول
الهجمات التي
استهدفت
المنشات النوويه الايرانيه كانت في الواقع
الان هجمات الا ان الهجوم همم الاخير الذي
همم
استهدف منشاه في
مدينه كراج همم غرب طهران كانت بواسطه
الطائرات مسيره
ومقتل همم العالم النووي الايراني تم
بواسطه الصاروخ بواسطه رشاش اوتوماتيكي تم
ادخاله الى ايران بواسطه اشخاص كما ان
الانفجار الذي حصل في منشات نابلس تم
نتيجه نقل مواد همم
انفجاريه الى داخل المنشاه لذا مساله
الاختراق ورد هناك اعتراف وتاكيد على ذلك
هناك همم الكشف عن كثير من الاختراقات
بواسطه السلطات الايرانيه
شكرا جزيلا على كل هذه المعلومات بالتاكيد
سنتابع معك اولا باول خلال هذه النشره
والمواعيد الاخباريه القادمه اي اا جديد
كنت معي من دبي الصحف المتخصص في شان
الايراني مسعود الفك